[Music]
some developing news for you right now a
source tells ET that Mike the situation
Sorrentino is officially a married man
got a ring on it for everything on the
Jersey stars Jersey Shore stars wedding
here's Entertainment Tonight producer
Brendan G Opry and Brendan what do you
know about the ceremony well it was
beautiful
from a photo we saw in social media
listen it all went down at Legacy
Council in New Jersey just a short time
ago a source at the wedding has
confirmed the exciting news to us we
know that the couple's entire Jersey
Shore family the cast was in attendance
at the wedding we assumed they were
filming we haven't confirmed that but we
would assume as they were currently in
production as of a couple weeks ago we
assume the wedding was filmed today it
looks like they have a great time I mean
a few of them are starting to post on
social media from the ceremony and it
looks the venue looks beautiful it's a
celebratory event how do we have anyone
on how the couple is feeling we haven't
spoken our source hasn't said how the
couple is feeling yet we do know that
they posted the couple did post on
social media earlier today Mike writing
I promise to be my best self every day
and make you proud to call yourself mrs.
Sorrentino love you with all my heart
Lauren also posting on Instagram earlier
today saying without you I wouldn't be
whole now it's baby-making time are they
I know I don't know I'm gonna sue me
that means she's ready to jump in I mean
you know what half you know you never
know what happens after a wedding hey
GTL WB Gym tan laundry wedding baby you
know Jersey syrup they used to be able
to about that GTL I love that we think
that they might be filming the wedding I
mean let's be real you know dang well
they were filming this wedding if he's
about to go on in general right
absolutely yeah he and he lucked out
actually this is a really special time
for him because his judge his attorney
recently a couple weeks ago had
submitted paperwork to have the time
when he had to check himself in a jail
pushed out so he doesn't actually have
to check himself in now until January
15th again obviously he's going to jail
for tax evasion
but he's got a couple months now to
celebrate this beautiful
moment with Lauren he'll be able to
enjoy the holidays with his family in
Jersey again before chucking himself in
a federal prison no sooner than the 15th
of January that's awesome despite what's
looming there's some great news there
and again a wedding is always fighting
George yeah so congratulations Mike
thank you so much Brendan thanks guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]